president biden says he's committed to
transparency at the border but he is not
talking about that today
instead just days after saying he was a
killer
president biden is inviting russian
leader vladimir putin to be part of a
white house virtual summit
on climate change china's president has
also been asked
white house correspondent peter ducey is
live on the north lawn with details on
all of this good evening peter
good evening brett for the first time
there is an issue that makes president
biden want to invite the leaders of a
country he called an opponent
russia's vladimir putin and a competitor
china's xi to a virtual meeting and that
issue is
climate change i haven't yet but they
know they're invited
but i haven't but i haven't spoken to
either one of them yet
he's already spoken to british prime
minister boris johnson about this
we talked a lot about climate change the
president is also now teasing
that he'll take on gun control with
executive orders looking at what kind of
authority i have relative to
important weapons as well as whether or
not i have an authority to
these new weapons that are being made
traveling with the president
son hunter hours after republican
senators ron johnson and chuck grassley
wrote to the secret service atf and fbi
asking for records related to a politico
report
that federal agents intervened when
hunter's then girlfriend
his brother bo's widow allegedly
improperly disposed of a gun in 2018
the secret service tells fox the agency
maintains there was no
secret service involvement in the matter
described at the border the
administration has still
only allowed cameras into a migrant
shelter run by hhs
no cameras inside the border patrol
processing facilities the new york times
described
as akin to jails i will commit to
transparency
and as soon as i am in a position to be
able to implement what we're doing
right now today some follow-up do you
have a time frame
for when the next round of cameras might
be allowed in oh we're working on it
hopefully
soon immigration was a main topic at the
president's first solo press conference
covet 19 never came up and neither did
his green jobs program
as the commander-in-chief called on
reporters from a staff prepared list
10 were on it 20 were not continuing
a pattern fox is the only member of the
five
network tv pool that has never been
on the list in front of the president
and i'm just curious but that is
official administration policy we're
here having a conversation aren't we
and do i take questions from you every
time you come to the briefing room yes
but
has the president taking questions from
you since you came in since you he came
into office
unfortunately yes or no only when i have
shouted after he goes through his whole
list and the president has been very
generous with his time with fox i'm just
curious about this
list that he has given so only member of
the five network pool never
on it dating back to when he resumed
in-person events in wilmington during
the
end of the campaign well i would say
that i'm always happy to have this
conversation with
you sometimes a staffer has that list
sometimes it is the president himself
and he doesn't always stick to it but it
has become part of the
official program in the last couple of
months we do not know when the next
formal solo press conference with the
president is going to be
we do know we don't expect to see much
of him this weekend he is at home in
wilmington
brett and of course the president's
welcomed on special report anytime
uh for an interview peter thank you